the next film is an alternate Joker
story Gotham has descended into purge
like condition chaos it order two parts
of humanity but maybe there's a greater
evil of this is rogue theory you can't
hear anything that was just said here
instead we're talking about Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker and how we know it
inspired a lot of other Joker's but
how's it going to inspire the Joker's
over Warner Brothers so a lot of these
people have some really insane theories
on it real quick
speaking of theories from the show but
not DC Marvel theories we're gonna be
live at La comic-con this Saturday
what's the date on that the 13 12 the 12
yeah
the 12 at 3:00 p.m. yes and just look us
up on the LA comic-con page and our
panel will be there throwing out some
rogue theories about what's actually
gonna happen in the MCU for phase 4 and
5 which kind of feels like they're not
telling us what the real Big Bad is
gonna be so we get into it then but on
today's episode we have Eric Eric past
is a biggest fan Dan Torsen I would say
they don't know that you know her on
this episode we're going to make some
final rogue predictions about also the
breaking bad movie El Camino before it's
released a real quick last week Zach
Huddleston off screen producer got the
most answers right about what was gonna
happen in the Joker movie and us were
forced to look at this weekly until he
gets dethroned by big predictions about
El Camino this week guys Joker made a
ton of money last weekend yeah and it's
there's already awards talk just so
having like a reverse last Jedi whole
thing in the cultural discourse
happening
so there's a lot of buzz going on about
this but basically that means that they
have a hit on their hands Joker is
inspiring the people at DC and at Warner
Brothers a lot there's obviously a lot
of people are saying no this movie's not
gonna have a sequel but
it good right they've changed their
minds a lot but also people have changed
our minds before and especially about
the way that they're approaching their
cinematic universe because they've
probably been looking for a new solution
so I want to hear theories rogue
theories on how the release and success
of Joker is going to affect the DC
Cinematic Universe whatever they call it
the dick you yeah I think that's a
general term
my theory is I'm calling this a Joker
multiple choice and I'm gonna explain
what this means
so I'm also Mike the drop was so fans of
the Joker
know that this movie is borrowing very
much from Alan Moore's The Killing Joke
graphic novel which famously depicts the
Joker in an origin story as a failed
comedian but the line that everyone
remembers is the Joker saying if I'm
going to have a past I prefer to be
multiple choice and a brief spoiler
warning if you have not seen Joker yet
but I'm not gonna say everything happens
in this movie it ends with this kind of
open-ended scene that suggests that
everything that we've seen in this movie
might be from an unreliable narrator it
might be fiction that the Joker or this
character this mentally ill person is
presenting as his kind of wish
fulfillment story so what if the next
film imagine a trailer that goes back to
that Arkham Asylum or our cur Arkham
state hospital scene where the
psychiatrist says goes yet but that was
all [ __ ] right he goes yeah it was a
joke you wouldn't get it but what about
this and then the next film is an
alternate Joker story alternate Joker
origin story that is completely
different numbers entirely new name
starts the beginning completely
dispelled walking Phoenix still Joaquin
Phoenix let's say in this one same actor
instead of a struggling comic what if he
is a returning vet from the battlefront
and he's struggling to get the help that
he needs Society has abandoned MS
Society is abandoned a lot of our vets
and the he's now applying his war
variances to urban life the way that
many people believe Heath Ledger's Joker
the way he got his scars was from an IUD
or something like that you shouldn't eat
those shouldn't he does but the idea so
that would be the next movies you see an
entirely new Joker multiple choice
selection so multiple choice option a
was what we just saw with ours or flick
multiple choice option B would be some
other Batman actor change to a name like
Cody Bale but the idea so that would be
the next movies we see an entirely new
Joker multiple choice selection so
multiple choice option a was what we
just saw with ours flick multiple choice
option B would be some other Batman
actor change to a name like Cody Bale
you know like C Bale Christian Bale you
know so some other possible Joker
apocryphal fiction right like another
story that Heath Ledger's character told
like his wife was a gambling addict and
then he carved up his face to make her
feel less bad and that's the story that
we see he's gonna all be based on other
Scorsese movies instead of taxi driver
in the king of comedy it could be a
gangland tale like you're like kind of
essentially pitching like this what is
it Schrodinger's cat like like Joker
origin story Joker is both alive and
dead because it doesn't matter until we
open the box but that box of Joker will
always take significantly Road I will
say terrible stakes for every other
Joker movie with like well none of this
is real it's awfully greed but I think
what I can imagine time Phillips saying
is like listen the character the Joker
is unique in that we do not ever know
definitively what his origin is and by
in his movie that way maybe he wants to
tell a series of films to prove that
point in driving home for everyone who
knows about what the Joker is and the
best argument Ford that being the truth
is what you said at the beginning he
purposely left it open for you to wonder
wait what here was real so you got three
Joker movies so you could put Joker
option B or Joker returning home from
war or Joker
war haunted or something like that those
are the next couple movies that they
could do with this
Joaquin Phoenix sugar and they're
arguably not sequels yes they're not
they're not they wouldn't Hollywood
Reporter's like yeah just equal hot cast
listeners you might not be twice to
learn Erick earned a rogue I think this
is obviously right for a sequel even
though that's clearly stated that the
money is there mm-hmm the tone is there
DC has found that dark tone that really
grounds it in a way that whether you
like the film or not I think it's like
easy to say that it was like it's that
tone that I don't think that DC has hit
very well it's very watchable yeah it's
very watchable it didn't feel like two
hours watchable yeah it's also like
actor bait I think anybody could see it
as that characters you know I would want
to be part of that universe as an actor
like oh my gosh you get so much free
rein to really explore the humanity of
every character we don't have a lot of
superpowers or anything like that yet
but obviously that grounds it but that'd
be an interesting thing to to take on
like kind of dead grass with that but
but yeah I think it's it's very right
for a sequel my thought is that will
turn into a trilogy of its own the idea
that now Joker's kind of the hero and
Batman's more of the antihero I think
from the implications of definitely
economically speaking Bruce Wayne's
father Thomas Wayne and like how he
affected the Joker's life whether you
believe that he's Joker's father or not
I don't know if we can say that but like
that definitely has far-reaching
implications and he's like economic
stranglehold on the city I mean we're so
willing to rise up in the joker movies
like three murders which are probably
not that uncommon in a city like that
yeah inspired people to go crazy well
that was probably part of the point to
them was how many people died in our
city every day but three wealthy white
boys right exactly let's not forget it
was Thomas Wayne going on the news and
saying they're part of my family
you're clowns because they're poor so
the state of Gotham is certainly you
know filled with tension I think that's
the thread that you pull I think that's
the the heart of it is that it's
following that political thread that
people I think resonated or didn't like
resonate you know polarize people
whether you feel like kind of left out
like Occupy Wall Street or something
like that you know like continue to
understand like why did Batman
why was he ever necessary why is the
city so full crime to begin with like
why why is someone like Batman necessary
other than like economically is it Wayne
Enterprises that's really you know has a
monopoly yeah taking over everything in
a way that makes people push back just
like in the Nolan series you know Batman
sort of creates Joker with his
theatricality mmm I think the reverse
could be true in this this world Joker
creates Batman yeah there's a vacuum
there that needs to be filled and then
the third one just to go even further
you know I think there's a third villain
where we get a joker Batman team-up
those two come together we get chaos we
get order Joker Batman team sides of the
same coin
I mean it is pretty rogue why are they
team up some third villain I think that
represents like an inhumane aspect or
something like that like chaos in order
to parts of humanity but maybe there's a
greater evil of a yeah that's like yeah
destructive in it's like complete
because the Joker needs like affirmation
and he needs like right like he's
dancing you know but he's dancing the
card the internet it's like he finally
has what he wants and if those people go
away like if that cast goes away like he
goes away right so later both of them
would be like no we need to keep things
not the way they are but at least here I
could see that Timo what's really
interesting about it being team up
against Lex Luthor is that obviously you
know you were saying to Occupy Wall
Street thing and that's what the Joker
is representing is a populist movement
of we got to take down the rich guy but
then they did right Thomas Wayne is not
irrelevant after this movie and then if
Bruce Wayne were to theoretically take
over but we all know Bruce Wayne doesn't
go do that he hangs out with Liam Neeson
instead so there's a vacuum in terms of
the the wealthy the base of you know
in halves and who better than Lex Luthor
yeah that's basically evil Wayne Corp
with his legs Corp so he introduces
another like class warfare kind of thing
but then it isn't seeing a Batman is
back
you know Batman's not siding with a Lex
Luthor type the house siding with an
Arthur Fleck type is also pretty crazy
yeah I guess he's a kid it's necessary
well so yang knows him Arnie awesome oh
did he just know him are they brothers
well right I think they're brothers I
don't know if we have speculations on
that but I crazy gene yes they have the
same dad with this twisted we expert is
the crazy gene gene with Lex Luthor
coming back for a candy the supercut of
him just laughing maniacally it's
fantastic it took a while for you to get
to but I think we're crazy there in
general everything you said was crazy
but then specifically also a Batman yeah
my turn everybody who well some people
who know me know that I left horror so
this goes into that realm of things yes
help me - it's so great and it's
Halloween time you guys owe the Joker
basically the plot of this movie is that
it's the purge okay
so it's immediately after the Joker ends
maybe like a couple days or months later
but basically Gotham has descended into
purge like conditions okay and Joker
like has his attention he has what he
wants he doesn't need to be the star of
this he could mean Joaquin Phoenix and
being in every wants but he's not gonna
get another Oscar so he probably doesn't
care so this is about sorry - really
yeah so this is about the way that all
the other villains come to be it's they
all of their origin stories okay and
I'll give you a pitch for two of them
and then a new hero so just like in the
purge you follow one like little family
or there's a bunch of purges but you see
you follow also seeing all the parchment
yes of course
of course of course of course in
theatres yes I have witches are there
enough to keep me out of the woods where
were they talking about you so just yes
so like the purge movies you follow one
like good like good cop right he's
trying to protect this little like group
of people or like one family or one like
group of teenagers or whatever so this
is this movie follows Harvey Dent
okay but this is obviously a different
Harvey Dent so Harvey Dent like in Joker
so in Joker they reference that he was a
spoiler or whatever tied to a radiator
as a child by his mother's boyfriend who
was abusive at the time when he was like
maybe eight or nine or something and so
this in my mind like this sort of
because the social services has been cut
and you know it's people are not I mean
this still happens now but like when you
call the police for help with domestic
violence it's very hard to prosecute so
Harvey Dent is a lawyer who was abused
as a kid and he goes into public service
because of that so his face is messed up
already it's not at the end of his life
it's at the beginning of his life so he
was tied to radiator as a kid and his
face is messed up yes and so he half of
his fate because those things actually
really do get hot if you're like in New
York and they have those old ones like
I've definitely burned myself on those
so he was abused by someone as a kid and
he has half of his face messed up and
that's from childhood and it's the
opposite of what normally happens so
people are pretty people are
good-looking and people are nice to them
and so this guy is a good kid but he has
a messed up face so everyone treats him
as if he's a bad guy
people think he's a criminal people
think he's like a bad lawyer so he grows
up and he becomes a public defender he's
not the district attorney he's just an
overworked public defender he's trying
to do good for the people and he come he
like is an adult and he became and he's
existing in this in purge reality that
the Joker has set off right so we follow
him
through the course of this movie like
just trying to make it just trying to
keep our protagonist he's our
protagonist right and so we just try to
stay with him keep
himself alive and he's trying to protect
people along the way whether it's his
clients or people who runs into whatever
so all but also so that's our main
character but also we also see the rise
of penguin okay who is a one-percenter
right yes so he is a one-percenter and
we see his rise right and so he is one
of these guys who is it's I think it's
called like a spate escape pod
capitalism or escape hatch capitalism
which which well that exists now which
is like people very very rich people now
who know that global warming is
happening and the earth is ending and so
they're buying yachts they're buying
like underground bunkers and they're
like buying Islands so that they can
literally win the oceans rise yeah you
are now trading in from God so he's been
preparing for this and he thought it was
gonna be global warming right but he's
the penguin so it ends up being this
purge like atmosphere so he's been
preparing he has liked guns he has
private security forces because he's
super rich and he ice caps are melting
they bring in penguins as part of their
lethal force well now that is part of my
theory but yeah yeah exactly
so there's penguins everywhere right
guys so but he who comes to power and we
see him go from just a rich guy to
basically participating in the purge
becoming a super villain but through his
money and through private security and
just like essentially being free to
wreak havoc as part of the purge the
other character that's we're gonna see
become a bad guy is scarecrow right but
he's in Arkham Asylum or mental hospital
or
a hospital whatever it is he's working
at the same time as I don't know her
name but the psychiatrist I don't think
we get her name not the one when he's
outside of the asylum with the word he's
inside the asylum list so he it's
implied that he at least murders her or
attempts to murder her you know and if
the blood is down the hallway and so
he's working in the same time like he is
he sees that trauma right like his
coworker gets murdered essentially in
front of him right he just gives up and
starts letting people out right he gives
up he starts he like starts
participating in the purge and we see
scarecrow be go from stable psychiatrist
psychologist to this is too much for me
and we see him go start participating in
you know hatchet murders or whatever you
want you know what I like there with the
so he's working at Arkham when final
scene and yes takes place and
theoretically murders happen is I mean
I'm gonna stretch it but there's a
somatic Lee potentially relevant moment
of he's you know in his office or
something or he opens his door and he
sees Joker's bloody yeah I'd watch it
all right let me just hear him again
real quick so remember and then I'll
ward any additional rookies your tweet
version deserves so starting with Erica
gun alright Joker multiple choice every
story of the Joker's origin is a lie
I always leave spaces in my tweets for
you yeah yeah I guess mine boiled down
would be Joker hero
Nolan esque trilogy okay you're allowed
to use other words yeah hashtag Joker be
good oh yeah this one's gonna be a hit
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you told me Joker too : the purge inning
and hashtag Joker's nothingness
I love the purge is already a noun or a
purpose is it can't be in the comments
if any of those got you excited for what
could happen or if you hated all of it
you can also let us know just make sure
to tweet at the person directly but
whoever by the end of the episode ends
up with the most rogue E's gets their
wish to come true have their wishes here
but also we're gonna get to what we
think is really gonna happen with that
El Camino movies that are being so vague
about right after we think our sponsors
this episode of new rockstars rogue
theory was sponsored by keeps two out of
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 the good news with today's
advancements in science keeps offers
proven treatments that can come back the
symptoms of hair loss keeps has
revolutionized the way men are treated
for hair loss you used to have to go to
the doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now thanks to keeps you can
visit a doctor online and get medication
delivered to your
home no more waiting rooms and no more
pharmacy checkout lines get doctor
attention and discreet drug delivery all
from the comfort and privacy of your own
home find out why keep says more 5-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100,000 men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication keeps
treatment start at just $10 a month plus
for a limited time you can get your
first month free if you are ready to
take action to prevent hair loss go to
keeps calm / rock stars to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
ke EPS calm / rock stars okay i'll
camino the Breaking Bad sequel news this
week on Netflix that means that this is
our last time to be able to talk about
it before we know it actually happens in
and there's a lot of questions circling
what is the the truth of what we find
Jesse in who else is gonna show up all
kinds of questions so we pushed our
questions on you guys you guys have some
answers Eve that out yes you're going to
be waiting pretty heavily on this if you
win you get to replace off-screen
producers that cuddle soon oh his head
shot on the back there podcast listeners
it's horrifying though up there if you
get if you get the most right and then
hear the worst does Jesse survive
survive the movie El Camino yes yes yes
that's my answer yes I'm there is do I
keep doing word yes or no
I'm very split on the reason from Reno
to keep it a short they're very excited
yes he dies I'm gonna say it's
incredibly meaningful he goes out on his
own terms though I feel like he is the
antithesis of Walter White Walter
White's started good and really became
yeah and Jesse started bad and it's
gonna become good and I think you know
we could even get a similar death that
mirrors Walters but that is ultimately
has consequences that are like far more
far-reaching in the positive that is
that solves cancer
[Music]
mystery of cancer yeah I think it's
something along those lines but I just
hate that's good
yes he does okay the question was yes to
answer your question directly I think
absolutely survives yes there's no way
they're going to kill him off because he
suffered so much and in fact I watching
the El Camino trailer it feels like
there's even some like Christ's
resurrection imagery with Jesse Pinkman
like there's like his disciples who he
returns to and they're like wait what
he's like
washing his father up he has like whip
marks how does that story and when you
move on you're already in the spiritual
form and he just has sent off into a
sunset not a death like he he goes off
into his paradise which for him is
Mexico or wherever yeah yeah you know I
don't think he's gonna die I think he
has some other kind of unfinished
business see him as a ghost in this
story
maybe his arc is already complete but he
has this kind of form of afterlife where
he still has unfinished business that
he's got to close the book on yeah say
goodbye to him yes he sounds very dead
I'm already dead yeah you could say that
like seeing Andrea die in a way was like
the death of his heart sure and he at
that point he just has like more to do
Marina just had a stroke I just I want
to change my answer okay he makes
everybody thinks he dies mmm and then
he's free forever like it isn't right
and he's bound to huh yes death yeah
like two episodes later is back alive
speaking of possibly fake deaths its
Walter Roy actually dead or might he be
alive and might he come back in this
movie I'm gonna say he is he is still
alive I know really you know he's dead
but the only reason I for certain when I
watch that finale the guy's dead it's
gonna be crazy if he doesn't die but
somebody did email us
to New York comic-con and they saw this
like you know a corkboard with a bunch
of yarn and it's like the crime
investigation they have all of like Jack
well curse people they have Jesse
pinkman's mug shot and under all the
people who died in the finale
it says deceased under them it does not
say deceased under Walter White a que
hice Wow and this is a significant
amount of time later so it's not like
they don't know I think in one of the
videos that we did on it that like you
know film theorists I think did the
whole thing how like you see the APB
person touches poles right and like oh
if you were shot they're having like
there's so has it won't and if you had
cancer at the time that might cause your
blood clot more likely than that Walt
could have survived I don't I don't know
if that's the case but I think it would
very interesting if you did survive and
the cops try to keep him alive so that
they could prosecute him yeah very sure
crazy the way hang wanted him to so so
you kind of went a couple of boys but
mostly were saying he's back yeah I'm
gonna say he's like Wow Wow alright what
do you think Dan alive maybe but yeah
barely alive maybe just kept I could see
the first scene in that instance being
like cutting right back to that part
where they're pulling him off the ground
they're going like he's barely with us
taking of the analyst taking the
hospital I personally think he's gonna
stay dead I think that won't happen
I think narrative Lee it's a decisive
death it's meaningful I think we can
show his impact on the characters in the
story through flashbacks mm-hmm I love
Walter why I want to see him alive again
but I think that would cheapen that
would tamper with right too much oh
pretty perfect TV show but you think you
might be in a coma well I was just
saying that off of Eric's idea more
living I think that he does die yes he's
not alive yes he's not alive he's dead
because it's perfect end of story
goodbye forever great alright guys what
is the final scene of the movie
you can go final shot if you want or you
can go final scene I'll go with final
shot so I think Jesse and the third act
will make it back to the neo-nazi meth
compound and I think as part of
dismantling Walt's legacy will blow up
this well and then the last thing we'll
see is like inglourious basterds
swastika burning that's great that's
cool I think it will be a
pulling away shot where Jesse's down on
the ground I also like to imagine he's
overdosed a chance overdose on what
candy no on blue candy meth me not candy
math but as a way of being like yes I'm
blowing something up or I'm doing
something I'm about to die I'm gonna
kind of be close to my ex-girlfriend the
way that she and knowing that you're
gonna die anyways feeling high on meth
oh you mean Jane that's just that Jesse
will return to drugs in this movie you
think but you also think he'll die at
the end fade away enjoying ya what do
you think okay so he drives so you think
it's gonna end the exact same way as El
Camino or I mean I'm Breaking Bad he's
driving away but except he's driving
into Canada right custer black and
you're like okay this is the end of
movie great and then it comes back we
follow a guy just like some guy some
character we don't know yet into the
snow and canada he finds a cabin in the
woods knock does a special knock jay old
jesse opens the door this character that
has been introduced hands him a wad of
cash and he hands him blue meth and
that's the end but it's in canada and he
had and he's the only one who knows how
to do it and he doesn't like he still
it's the only skill he has so he has to
go back to it but he lives a life of
peace and solitude and he only lets this
one guy deal and that's the way it is no
you knock on a door get handed a baggie
there's no drones finally i asked how
many times are we gonna hear jesse
pinkman say [ __ ] in this movie i think
once we get one time once i mean it's
gonna be the final line it's gonna be
like burn [ __ ] 27 it's gonna be like
i'm skipping you it's 27 because it's
like remember when 24 was on TV and
Kiefer Sutherland found out that people
would do drinking games from him saying
there's no time right
it's like that it but the but Jesse
pinkman's the actor knows that that
people are doing drinking games on that
place so he's gonna work in a lot of
[ __ ] dan how many times I would say I
think it's gonna be the rule of threes I
think we're gonna get on like a soft one
I think we need a one that's like soft
[ __ ] I think it's like kind of like
offhanded one he's not calling someone a
[ __ ] but he's like nice a [ __ ] yeah
and then yeah it's like magnets [ __ ]
and we'll do okay cool so that's those
are our Breaking Bad questions I'm gonna
I don't have to or druggies there but
I'm gonna give Marino on yes she gave us
so much movie guys so we're gonna dive
into our last segment here it's gonna be
rogue questions
roadies are up for grabs you could
totally change the points although
everything could change remember that
the winner at the end of this with the
most roadies gets their wish to come
true all right and I'm sure they're
selfish wishes and nothing that we can't
make happen on this show it came out
this week that Jared Leto was upset to
be left out of the Joker Oh what this
you know that he isn't the leader so
what do we need to do to make it up to
Jared Leto nothing dead cat or like used
condoms new spider-man ride being built
at Disneyland will supposedly let guests
shoot webs out of their wrists what's
the best use of wrist webs
while you're at wisdom Elance with Neal
and Disneyland it's when you're like at
the back of the line but you know how it
loops around and you can see the front
of the line you grab the person in the
front line you switch yourself so you
are actually in the front of the line
and then just so fast they snap her neck
these are the full like yeah
high-density wire oh boy
I would say just messing with the
characters you know yeah just another
obstacle for those poor poor characters
in their suits just like webbing there
they're like sillies doing oh they're
gonna think you use it to break out a
Disney jail like the guy's the real
supervillain of Joker was the super rats
I'm glad we're talking about this
finally because I want to know what
powers does a super rad have could
deliver pizza to any outside fresh Rogge
and that's the what are your totals
three two and 3/8
[Applause]
dan has to dance for the rest of the
episode yep it's name wasn't Dan oh yeah
so that's it for this episode of rogue
theory thanks so much for going rogue
with us thanks to our guest Eric Foss
Maria mattress and Anderson Dan where
can we find you we have to look Monday's
usually what's your Herald team name my
whole team's name is joyride there you
go joy joy ready Joetta used to be Eric
what do we got coming out we have some
more takes on things you might have
missed in the Joker specifically with
Thomas Wayne's character and again come
to Le Comic Con if you live in LA area
this this Saturday the 12th at 3 p.m.
and if you're in the LA area if you
can't make it to that I'm doing a play
Thursday Friday and Saturday
slaughtering the swampland to find me on
Twitter on Twitter at Marina masterís
hey guys make sure to get this feed on
podcast first so that you can hear this
disgusting dance this is not the Joker
dance
this is worse more psychopathic also you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram I
thought Molina followed new rock stars
at new rock stars guys support us on
patreon - it really helps a lot thank
you guys so much
keep dancing
[Music]